maureen
the the visual
demands an explanation so please
please tell us where are you first of
all you're coming to us from which uh
which part of the world uh spring arbor
michigan spring arbor michigan yeah and
um are you in a cabin or a rural area i
am in a rural area uh we just got
internet out here hey yeah for real for
real yeah whoa yeah it's a real [ __ ]
show and
are you okay do you need help yeah well
i hear all these npr stories about these
people who don't have internet and i'm
those people and yeah
but you know what i mean there's an
upset there's an upside to it i mean i
don't know that thoreau was quite happy
when he walked away from the world uh it
for a lot of people swear by it and so
you may decide
um after checking out our podcast and
talking to us that you don't want
internet anymore
i started doing some really weird [ __ ]
when i didn't have internet exhibits a b
and c so i don't know well well tell us
uh i'm curious what's going on behind
you what is it that you do what it what
these bones i see behind you and it
looks like
i don't know eagle eagle feathers and
nope that's illegal
oh
did i say
eagle
feathers uh
i meant say it you just
you just can't have them
yeah so those are not eagle feathers i
will point out to people you're not
going around killing eagles good
uh well tell us what is it what do you
do uh so i work for a taxidermist oh
yes
that makes sense yeah yeah and uh
the feathers you see behind me that's my
uh former best friend pee wee that my
mom ran over and i
didn't want to say goodbye and so i
taxidermied him with my boss
wait
just
what was pee-wee
was a peacock okay oh god okay okay i
thought you ran over your friend pee-wee
yeah and he happened to be wearing uh an
exotic coat when you ran into him
no so you're so that's a peacock behind
you that's been taxidermied your mother
how do you accidentally run over the
most visible animal in the world yeah i
mean it's
peacock walking traffic it's yeah it's
so it's it's insane you can't oh i
didn't see that peacock
well she claimed she didn't but
so he really hated her i think he could
sense that i loved her wait you suspect
foul play
no not not on her part um in her defense
wait i mean who hated who the peacock
hated your mother peewee hated my mom
and my husband
um
and how would how did this manifest
itself did he attack them or was it
mostly threatening threatening letters
no it was
he he attacked dear sir
written with my own plumage quilt
he wrote so wait so he's ready this
these are his feet right here
oh my god
[Applause]
maureen is now holding up
some taxidermied uh
peacock feet now really worried when
your husband passes away
he'll be made into a coffee table
hey his feet could be door stoppers yeah
i'm just saying what better way to hold
the door open that's a great idea
deceased husband's uh petrified feet so
so um anyway you're my you suspect that
maybe the bird attacked your mother
watched it and heard it and
then watched it yeah it was terrible i
drank for weeks
how old were you it was just a year ago
last week oh yeah okay i'm sober now so
it's cool but okay it was it was very
traumatic it was awful i'm sorry i'm i'm
all joking aside i'm sorry i mean seeing
an animal that you love get killed
my daughter saw it her friend saw it bad
oh boy so
then but then
you
taxidermied you know that's gotta be
isn't that emotionally difficult to
taxidermy an animal that you having a a
connection with so
for some reason so that's why i started
doing it because
um
i don't deal with death well
so
i like i just can't let them go and
having them around i know they like
they're not literally still in there but
having their body still around
uh
helps me deal with it and so right right
you know
when i taxidermied them they're
they're still with me and
um i think there's no um
no i i understand that and i'm i'm sure
that's that's been no but i i do i
unders that's actually been i mean
historically that's all throughout
mankind is trying to figure out ways to
keep people with us uh so
and loved ones with us i mean the
egyptians did that the i think the
egyptians not only mummified their
rulers and and uh the wealthy but they
also mummified uh i believe cats yeah
they did yeah so um
and they were right about just about
everything i mean we all live in
pyramids now right